.
* Afrikanischer Gesang *
* Kräftiger afrikanischer
Kindergesang, Stimmengewirr *
(Mann) Wir haben heute
eine ganz besondere Person bei uns.
Das Schweizerische Rote Kreuz
hat eine Botschafterin geschickt.
Es ist mir ein Vergnügen,
euch Dominique vorzustellen!
Vielen Dank. Es ist mir
eine grosse Freude, hier zu sein.
Ich war Skirennfahrerin ― ihr wisst
wahrscheinlich nicht, was das ist,
ich werde es euch später zeigen.
Vor fünf Jahren
habe ich die Goldmedaille
an den Olympischen Spielen gewonnen.
Ich hoffe, dass ich etwas
für euch verändern kann,
wenn ich in die Schweiz zurückkehre
und eure Geschichte erzähle.
Ich danke euch herzlich
für den warmen Empfang.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Sanfte Musik *
* Der Schnee knirscht. *
* Vogelzwitschern *
Als ich jung war,
führten wir ein Vagabundenleben.
Wir wohnten in Zermatt,
am Greifensee, in Visp.
Dann im Engadin.
Aufgewachsen bin ich im Engadin.
Da war ich
zwischen vier und elf Jahre alt.
Als wir nach Engelberg
gezogen sind, war es einfach,
weil meine Grosseltern dort
ein Ferienhaus besassen.
Wir hatten die Ferien oft dort ver-
bracht, viel Familie war schon da.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Unsere Eltern
haben uns immer sehr unterstützt.
Es war nicht immer einfach,
auch finanziell.
Drei Kinder -
und eine so teure Sportart.
Im Nachhinein realisiere ich schon,
worauf sie verzichtet haben.
Wir gingen kaum in die Ferien.
Und wenn, dann in der Nähe.
Das war natürlich
auch von ihrer Seite ein Opfer.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Hello, Dad. Salü.
Geht es gut?
- Ja, danke.
Schön, schön.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Das ist ja nicht schlimm.
Es sieht doch gut aus.
Stimmt's?
- Yes.
(Bea) Dominique
war ein sehr aufgewecktes Kind.
Sie war immer sehr weit.
Man hatte immer das Gefühl,
sie sei ihrem Alter voraus.
Mit sechs Monaten stand sie im Bett,
mit zehn Monaten konnte sie laufen.
Dominique stellten wir sehr früh auf
die Ski, was etwas egoistisch war.
Wir waren
sehr begeisterte Skifahrer.
Wir sind wirklich bei jedem ...
Bei jeder Möglichkeit
waren wir auf den Ski.
Sie hat sofort mitgemacht
und fand es super.
(Beat) Sie wollte auch immer
überall hinauf. Überall, immer.
Und auch mit dem Stehen,
dann auf die Ski ...
In der Wohnung ist sie
mit den Ski herumgetrippelt.
Sie wollte das einfach selbst lösen,
selbst können
und selbst auf die Spitze bringen
und vielleicht auch verarbeiten.
Auch wenn sie etwas gemacht hat ...
Man musste ihr nie sagen,
man könnte es besser ...
Sie wollte es selbst besser machen.
Heute haben wir einen besonderen
Tag, das Mädchen hat Geburtstag.
Und, was darf es?
- Ski fahren.
Ski fahren.
Meine Skikarriere
hat wahrscheinlich angefangen,
als ich etwa sieben Jahre alt war.
Ich mochte den Skisport
einfach sehr gerne.
Meine Eltern schickten mich
in den Skiklub.
1996, ich war elf Jahre alt,
konnte ich erstmals
das wichtigste Rennen des Jahres,
den Ovo-Grand-Prix-Final
für mich entscheiden.
Vreni Schneider und Mike von Grüni-
gen waren meine Kindheitshelden,
die dann auf einmal vor uns standen
und uns Autogrammkarten verteilten.
Mir haben sie
die Medaille übergeben.
Das steigerte meine Motivation,
diesen Weg weiterzugehen und
in diese Richtung zu gehen, extrem.
1996, als ich dieses Rennen -
den Ovo-Grand-Prix in Sils - gewann,
sind wir
in die Zentralschweiz gezogen.
In der Zentralschweiz war damals
eine andere Athletin zuvorderst,
das war Fabienne Suter.
Fabienne hatte immer starkes Heimweh
und reiste nicht gerne.
Dadurch kam ich noch mehr in den
Genuss von internationalen Rennen.
Ich fuhr in jenem Jahr
v.a. im Slalom sehr, sehr gut.
Dann ging es darum,
wer an dieses internationale Rennen
nach Sarajevo durfte.
Fabienne wollte nicht und ich durfte
von der Zentralschweiz aus hingehen.
* Leichte Musik,
Brummen des Flugzeugmotors *
(TV-Kommentar)
Ecco Michela Figini.
La ragazza che ieri era al comando
e che aveva nettamente
dominato le concorrenti.
22:34 il miglior tempo.
Impostata bene questa curva.
Ecco ora un cambio a sinistra,
entra nella porta rossa.
Sempre alta, sta andando bene.
Ha controllato bene gli sci
e sopportato le vibrazioni.
Ora una curva importantissima.
È riuscita
a mantenersi abbastanza alta.
Migliora nettamente il tempo.
Attenzione al salto!
Tra un attimo il traguardo
nel tempo di 1:13:36.
1:13:36 - cancellata
la prestazione della Kirchler.
(Platzspeakerin) Gold medal,
olympic champion:
Michela Figini, Švajcarska,
Switzerland.
* Jubel *
* Emotionale Musik *
* Brummen des Flugzeugmotors *
Hola!
Ciao!
- Ciao!
Hattest du einen guten Flug?
Ja.
- Kompliment, grossartig!
Adesso vedete.
- Certo.
Andiamo.
Hier ist unser kleiner Flieger.
Wollen wir?- Klar!
Tutto apposto?
- Certo.
* Ruhige, monotone Klänge *
Ich mache den rolling Take-off.
Tutto apposto?
Runway 15 identified.
52.
Power full, enter page.
Power gut.
Speed's rising,
temperature's rising. Und rotieren.
* Sanfte Musik,
Brummen des Flugzeugmotors *
Wir sind unterwegs Richtung Split
in Kroatien.
Dort halten wir, um zu tanken.
Und dann haben wir noch
eine wunderschöne Etappe vor uns,
Split ― Sarajevo.
Ich bin ziemlich aufgeregt.
Es ist das erste Mal nach 19 Jahren,
dass ich Sarajevo besuche.
Und für dich?
Für mich ist es das erste Mal
seit 35 Jahren!
Wirklich?
Ja, es ist sehr emotional für mich.
- Für mich auch.
Ich habe wunderschöne Erinnerungen
an dieses olympische Abenteuer.
Danach kam der Krieg
und alles veränderte sich dort.
Diese schrecklichen Bilder ...
Die machten mir Angst,
dass der Zauber von damals
kaputtgehen könnte.
* Brummen des Flugzeugmotors *
* Sanfte Musik *
Genau hier haben wir damals
dieses Foto unserer Ankunft gemacht.
Es gab sicher noch mehr davon.
Was für ein Sauwetter.
Hast du das gesehen?
Es schneite an jenem Tag,
da war so viel Schnee.
Ich erinnere mich noch gut.
Wie sich das verändert hat.
Mir bleibt die Luft weg.
Es waren so spitzige Häuschen.
Ich glaube,
die waren für die Zeitmessung
oder für andere Dinge
im Zusammenhang mit dem Wettkampf.
Der Sessellift war das Ziel?
Ja, da war das Ziel.
Da waren
so viele Journalisten.
Ich war 18 Jahre alt
und ziemlich klein.
Diese vielen Journalisten,
das hat mich komplett überwältigt.
Ich wusste nicht mehr,
wohin ich sollte.
Ich war irgendwie
von Prato Leventina im Tessin
an die Olympischen Spiele
nach Sarajevo katapultiert worden.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Die Musik schwillt an. *
* Sanfte Musik, Vogelzwitschern *
Als ich nach Sarajevo reiste,
hatte ich all diese schönen Bilder
der Stadt im Kopf,
wie im Bilderbuch.
Eine schöne Stadt mit Bergen.
Als ich ankam, fand ich
eine komplett zerstörte Stadt vor.
Es war nur ein einziges Hotel offen
und nur eine Bank,
die wiederaufgebaut worden war.
* Nachdenkliche, harfenartige Musik *
Das hat mich sehr berührt.
Ich war ja noch ein junges Mädchen
und konnte für einen Moment
bildlich vor mir sehen,
was ein Krieg anrichtet.
Das hat mich sehr geprägt
in meinem Leben.
Erinnerst du dich noch
an dein Gefühl,
als du hier mit den Ski ankamst?
Ja, aber ich denke,
es war für mich anders als für dich.
Klar, ich durfte hier Ski fahren,
das war sehr wichtig,
aber ich erinnere mich v.a.
an die Stadt, an meinen ersten Flug,
mit Gepäck, das ist mir alles
viel präsenter als der Wettkampf.
Es war ein Wettkampf unter Jugendli-
chen, das Niveau war nicht so hoch.
Für dich war es anders, für dich
war es dein wichtigstes Rennen.
Ich schwebte irgendwie
über dem Boden.
Das war alles so emotional,
dass ich das erleben durfte,
nicht nur die Wettkämpfe, sondern
auch das ganze Drum und Dran.
Das sind Erinnerungen,
die mir wahrscheinlich
mein Leben lang bleiben werden.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ta-raa!
Power full, speed's rising,
temperature's rising.
Rotieren.
* Sanfte Musik *
Als ich aus Sarajevo zurückkam,
fuhr ich in der Zentralschweiz das
nächste interregionale Slalomrennen.
Nach dem ersten Lauf lag ich mit
extrem viel Vorsprung in Führung.
Ich glaube, ich lag sogar
ein wenig vor dem besten der Jungs.
Und im zweiten Lauf
riss dann das Kreuzband.
(Laut) Ah!
- (Speaker) ... leider gestürzt.
Hoi zusammen und willkommen zurück
auf meinem Videoblog,
heute zur Physiotherapie
in der Rennbahnklinik in Muttenz.
Die Physiotherapie ist sehr gut
eingerichtet mit vielen ...
Die schwierigste Phase während
meiner Zeit als Nachwuchsfahrerin
war sicher, als ich die
ganz schweren Verletzungen hatte.
2001, 2002, 2003.
Wenn ich an diese Zeit denke ...
Ich denke selten so zurück, wie ich
es jetzt mache, im Sinne von:
"Das war dann, dann passierte das
und dann passierte das."
Ich hatte das Kreuzband gerissen.
Ich war drei Jahre lang verletzt,
fiel zurück, war wieder verletzt.
Als ich mit 14 Jahren schon so
schwer verletzt war, war klar,
dass mein grosser Traum, Skirenn-
fahrerin zu werden, etwas war,
das vielleicht
nie wahr werden würde.
Das war auch etwas, das mich
als Mensch extrem weiterbrachte.
Ich gestaltete einen Teil von Plan B
sehr aktiv aus.
* Kirchturmuhr *
Wie geht es Bruder Kuno?
- (Mann) Gut.
Sie waren
meine mathematischen Begleiter.
Schon, ja.
Sie hatte ich schon im ersten Gymi.
- Da hatte ich alle.* Er lacht. *
Sie unterrichteten immer erstes UG.
- Ja, immer erstes UG.
Die Präfekten sagten, es sei im Kol-
legium ruhiger, wenn ich es mache.
Schon?- Ja.- So lustig.
- Ich weiss nicht weshalb.
Sehr lange, bis ich an der ETH war,
sagte ich immer,
Pater Leonhard sei der intelli-
genteste Mensch, den ich kenne.
Sie waren so klar.
Auch jetzt, wenn man mit
Ihnen spricht, es ist alles so ...
Durchsichtig
- Ja, genau. Ist das blöd?
Nein, das ist schon recht,
aber ich bin nicht der Gescheiteste.
Für mich waren Sie das lange.
Sie konnten einfach
so klar erklären.
Ich weiss noch ...
Das sagte man mir immer, ich könne
gut erklären. Das sagten sie immer.
Pater Leonhard konnte mich
in diese Welt reinziehen.
Ich wollte immer mehr
über Mathematik und Physik wissen.
Er hat mich extrem inspiriert,
nachher Physik zu studieren.
Bevor ich an die ETH kam,
hatte ich schon so viel gesehen.
Natürlich haben wir nicht alles
ganz tief behandelt.
Sie haben uns
von allem etwas gezeigt.
Wir haben die ganze spezielle
Relativitätstheorie durchgerechnet.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass ich es nicht verstanden habe.
Sie machten immer die Aufgabe
mit dem Auto und dem Apfel.
Das weiss ich nicht mehr.
Das Auto fährt und man wirft
den Apfel aus dem Auto.
Man musste zeichnen,
wie der Apfel auf den Boden fällt,
für den Beobachter,
der aussen beim Auto war.
Fragt mich jemand nach
der speziellen Relativitätstheorie,
nenne ich immer dieses Beispiel.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ich stiess sehr jung - vielleicht
war ich zwölf oder 13 Jahre alt -
auf die Bücher des Dalai Lama
und von Thich Nhat Hanh.
Ich fing an,
buddhistische Literatur zu lesen.
Das war Zufall, einfach weil es
bei uns in der Bibliothek war.
Ich hatte schon vorher
viel über die Kreuzritter gelesen,
auch über die Hexenverfolgungen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
das sei ein schwieriger Teil
der Geschichte, der Religion
und der Kultur,
in der ich aufgewachsen bin.
In den buddhistischen Büchern
habe ich eine Alternative gefunden,
die mich sehr angesprochen hat
und von der ich sehr fasziniert war.
Mit 13 kam ich an die Stiftsschule,
ans Gymnasium in Engelberg.
Das Gymnasium in Engelberg
ist eine Klosterschule.
Ich bin protestantisch aufgewachsen,
also auch reformiert.
Ich bin
in die katholische Schule gekommen.
Ein unheimliches Schlüsselerlebnis
war für mich,
dass diese Pater
meine Lehrer waren.
So viele Lehrpersonen,
die sich mit uns Jugendlichen
auseinandergesetzt haben,
mit unseren Fragen
und auch mit unseren kleinen Krisen.
Das hat mir sehr viel Frieden
mit meiner eigenen Kultur gebracht.
Das war etwas vom Schönsten,
das ich aus dieser Schulzeit
mitnehmen durfte.
* Heitere Klänge *
Hier sieht es immer noch gleich aus,
es riecht auch noch genau gleich.
Da haben wir gearbeitet.
Wenn man Pater Leonhard suchte,
fand man ihn immer hier.
Ich habe immer noch
meine Burg da hinten.
So gut.
Da ist meine Burg.
Ja, ganz genau so war es immer.
- Ja, ja.
Sogar der Drucker
ist noch der gleiche.
Der läuft und läuft und läuft.
Und ich bin tatsächlich
neben Albert Einstein,
das ist beinahe etwas
zu viel der Ehre.* Sie lacht. *
Da ist immer noch Pater Thomas.
- Ja.
Mir ist nur aufgefallen,
dass sie sehr rasch verstand.
Sie war eine dieser Schüler,
die ich hatte:
einmal gesehen, immer gewusst.
Wir haben natürlich immer -
auch Pater Roman und Kuno usw. -
ferngesehen,
wenn wieder ein Rennen war.
Wir hatten immer Angst davor,
dass sie stürzt.
Und dann: "Oje, jetzt ist sie
wieder gestürzt."
"Hoffentlich
hat sie sich nicht verletzt."
Dann musste sie
wieder operiert werden.
Wie viele Operationen hattest du,
etwa zehn?
Wenn sie nicht stürzte, sagten wir:
"Oh, jetzt war sie gut."
* Sanfte Streicherklänge *
* Sanfte Streicherklänge,
Wasser plätschert *
Es waren eigentlich schöne Optionen.
Sie haben mir aber damals
einfach nichts bedeutet -
im Vergleich zu diesem grossen
Kindheitstraum, den ich immer hatte.
(Bea) Sie musste schon kämpfen.
Sie hat den Numerus clausus für
ein Medizinstudium locker bestanden.
Sie hätte den Weg
zur Militärpilotin gemacht.
Das hat ihr alles
nicht so viel bedeutet.
Dann war es wirklich so,
dass ich sie auf die Ski
gescheucht habe
oder sie sollte etwas machen,
damit es ihr wieder besser ging.
So konnte es nicht enden.
Ich konnte nicht zu Hause liegen
und denken: "Das war's."
Es war nicht fertig.
* Pulsierende, temporeiche Musik *
(Mann) Hopp, hopp, hopp.
(Mann) Sie war wirklich stark
im Slalom
und den technischen Disziplinen.
Mit ihren Verletzungen ...
Der Slalom
ist für den Körper belastender.
Man musste ... Die schnellen
Disziplinen kamen automatisch dazu.
(Mann) Speed mit Dominique -
das war für mich klar.
Gleich vom ersten Jahr an,
als sie in meiner Gruppe war
und ich mit ihr
zusammenarbeiten konnte.
Es war eigentlich klar, dass sie
Speed fahren sollte und musste.
Ich glaube, der erste Tag auf den
Abfahrtsski war auf der Ibergeregg -
zumindest habe ich es so
in Erinnerung.
Ich fuhr beinahe
in den Skilift hinein.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung,
wie ich mit diesen 2,10-m-Ski
oder 2-m-Ski, - egal, was es war -,
wie ich damit eine Kurve
machen sollte, mit meinen Knien.
(Dominique) Am Anfang sah es wild
aus, aber sie war sehr lernfähig.
Hat man ihr etwas vorgeschlagen,
konnte sie es schnell umsetzen.
Dominique hat einfach nicht aufge-
geben. Ich weiss auch nicht, warum.
Ich weiss nicht, was er in mir sah.
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
Für mich war klar: "Ich bin da,
und ich bin da, wo ich hingehöre,
und jetzt muss ich
diese Chance packen."
Für die Mannschaft war es schwierig,
dass ich aus dem Nichts
gekommen bin.
Niemand kannte mich
und ich war auf einmal so schnell.
Für die anderen war es schwierig,
damit umzugehen.
Mein Empfinden der Situation war so:
Es war immer noch zu wenig gut.
Es war nicht gut genug,
dass die anderen
zur Rangverkündigung blieben.
Es war nicht gut genug,
dass sich die Trainer freuten.
Niemand ausser mir freute sich,
dass ich so schnell war.
Es war immer dieses Gefühl,
dass es zu wenig war.
Und da war dieses Gefühl,
das Messer am Hals zu haben:
"Wenn ich es jetzt nicht packe,
bin ich wieder weg."
"Dann bin ich wieder
im Niemandsland."
"Dabei kämpfte ich so lange,
um da rauszukommen."
(Speakerin) Mesdames et messieurs.
Bienvenue aux Jeux Olympiques
d'hiver 2010 à Vancouver.
* Tosender Jubel *
Ich bin nach Vancouver gereist:
Das Wetter war übel, nur Regen.
In der ersten Woche
wurden alle Trainings abgesagt.
Als wir endlich
auf die Piste durften,
war die ganze Piste
ein einziges Wellblech.
Dann hiess es:
"That's it. Jetzt müsst ihr fahren."
* Startsignal *
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
Ich dachte:
"Hey, das ist deine Chance!"
"Nimm das Herz in die Hand
und pack diese Chance,
denn die nächste kommt erst
in vier Jahren wieder."
Ich bin Vollgas gefahren.
Mit einer der besten Zwischenzeiten,
also eigentlich auf Medaillenkurs,
zum letzten Sprung gekommen ...
Und dann ...
* Das Publikum schreit auf. *
Und dann liegst du dort im Ziel.
Ich hatte glücklicherweise nur
eine leichte Gehirnerschütterung.
Dort ist wirklich ...
Mein Skifahrerherz
ist in Vancouver gebrochen.
* Monotone, quälende Musik *
Schon die Verletzung
vier Wochen zuvor -
- nach allem, was ich
schon durchgemacht hatte -
war eine Riesenenttäuschung.
Trotzdem gab ich alles
für dieses Rennen in Vancouver.
Trotzdem war ich mir so sicher,
dass ich in Vancouver
diese Medaille holen konnte.
Wegen des letzten Sprungs,
wegen des letzten Tores,
hatte es nicht geklappt.
Ich fand dann einfach -
Entschuldigung für den Ausdruck:
"Aber welcher Vollidiot überlegt
sich so eine Geschichte?"
"Wenn es das Schicksal gibt ..."
"(Lachend) Was ist das
für ein Schicksal?"
"Du kannst doch nicht einfach so
dort im Ziel liegen."
"Nach allem, was du investiert hast,
war es quasi der Lohn,
in diesem Vancouver
im Ziel zu liegen."
(Mann) Vancouver
war der härteste Moment für mich,
in der Empathie für sie.
Ich erlebte das richtig hart,
gemeinsam mit ihr.
Der Grund war folgender:
Wir bauten über Jahre
eine Strategie auf,
die ihr in der Vorbereitung
Sicherheit vermitteln sollte,
dass sie loslassen
und an ihr Limit gehen konnte.
Ich merkte, dass das für sie
ein Bedürfnis war,
dass sie darin
eine Erklärung finden konnte.
Dominique brauchte eine Erklärung,
um auch das wieder
hinter sich lassen zu können.
* Sanfte,
vereinzelte Gitarrenklänge *
Gratuliere!
- Thank you.
Ja, great.
- Get ready?
Ist noch ein wenig ...
Mal sehen. Im Wald geht es sicher,
aber vielleicht oben ...
Sie wollen es durchbringen.
Das wird schon gutgehen.
- Yes.
Ein Husky.
Es kommt gut.
Uh.
Porta fortuna.
Dominique war für mich
in allererster Linie
ein ganz grosses Vorbild.
Als kleines Mädchen
wollte ich ihr alles nachmachen.
Das war wohl oft sehr anstrengend
für sie, sowie auch für Marc.
Ich bin ihnen immer hinterher,
egal, was es war.
* Leichte Gitarrenmusik,
sanftes Vogelzwitschern *
(Beat) Wohin gehst du heute?
- Auf den Titlis.
Was macht man dort?
Auf jeden Fall nicht Ski fahren.
Was sonst?
Ski fahren!
* Beat lacht. *
Michelle war natürlich immer
meine sehr, sehr junge Schwester.
Uns trennen fast neun Jahre.
Sie hat ...
- Aua!
... meine schwierige Zeit erlebt,
als sie sechs,
sieben, acht Jahre alt war.
Das war eine Zeit,
die sie sicher sehr prägte:
Ich war oft verletzt, es ging mir
in diesem Sport oft nicht so gut.
Es hat uns alle sehr überrascht,
dass sie trotzdem diesen Weg
auch für sich wählte.
(TV-Kommentar)
Allora attendiamo il traguardo.
Forza Michelle.
Restare davanti a Mikaela Shiffrin!
2:21:87 ...
Sì! 2:20:90.
* Jubel *
(Speaker) Olympic Champion,
Switzerland -
Michelle Gisin.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Ich begann mit ihr zu arbeiten.
Ich versuchte, ihr alles zu geben:
all meine Erfahrung
und mein Erlebtes,
die Verletzungen,
die Rennen, der Druck,
die Situationen, die ich hatte.
Sie sollte nicht
die gleichen Fehler machen
und nicht dieselben Momente
erleben müssen wie ich.
Ich spüre, dass die Arbeit
von Jahr zu Jahr weniger wird.
Oder sie verändert sich -
das trifft es eher.
Als ich zum ersten Mal da war,
zeigte ich ihr in praktisch jeder
Kurve, wo der Kurvenansatz ist,
zu welchem Punkt
sie fahren musste
und was zu tun ist,
wenn ein Fehler passiert.
In jeder zweiten Kurve schaute sie
mich mit grossen Augen an.
Und jetzt ist sie
schon sehr professionell.
Sie hat viel mehr Erfahrung.
Sie hat mehr Kapazität,
das merkt man.
Sie weiss sehr gut, was sie will.
Es gibt punktuelle Momente, wo sie
zurückschaut, dann gehe ich hin.
In den anderen Momenten
hat sie es im Griff
und ich weiss,
dass sie es richtig macht.
Ich rede nicht über 0,5 m,
auch nicht über 1 m.
Du darfst einfach
nicht ganz aus dem Kurs fallen.
Du darfst nicht
jenseits der Hügel fallen.
Wir haben einfach diese Momente,
in denen ich einfach zuhören muss.
Das musste ich lernen.
Es war klar: Wenn sie mir
auf einer Besichtigung sagt,
wie es ist
und wie es sich anfühlen wird,
dann höre ich einfach zu und muss
nicht als Schwester diskutieren.
Dann ist ganz klar,
dass ich einfach zuhören muss
und zwar ganz gut, denn was sie mir
sagt, wird mir extrem helfen.
Sag mir zwei wichtige Punkte!
Beim Tickety für das Tempo
und die Welle bereit.- Mhm.
Überall schön mitgehen.
Und dann ...
Ich würde sagen,
ab ein Tor vor Coaches' Corner,
also schon zwei vorher,
aber von dort an umstellen
und wirklich den Flow mitnehmen,
damit es in den Kurven aufgeht.
Perfect!
Spannung halten, bereit sein.
Schön mitgehen, gefühlvoll.
Geduld - und ...
Nach vorne ziehen, darauf,
Spannung ...
Gefühlvoll.
Ganz genau so.
Ganz genau so!
* Der Wind bläst kräftig. *
Diesen Moment vergesse ich nie mehr.
Ich stand unten am Parking.
(Tamara Wolf) Du bist früh ge-
startet, ich in den 40ern.- Ja, ja.
Wir liefen runter.
Stygi und Fränzi
hatten bereits ein Auto.
Ich fragte, ob wir
noch Tamaras Fahrt schauen könnten.
Ich stand auf dem Parkplatz und von
dort sieht man oben den Fallaway.
Du kamst wie ein Pfeil angeschossen.
Du kamst viel zu tief
aus dem Fishnet.
Ich dachte: "Brems, brems!"
Du bist
voll auf die Kanten gestanden ...
Einfach ... Wie in eine Mauer.
Das vergesse ich nie.
Ich bin zu spät reingekommen
und ich wusste genau,
dass es nicht reichen würde.
Ich dachte: "Gut, was mache ich?"
"Bremse ich vorher ab?"
"Nein, ich bremse nachher ab."
Ich bin irgendwie
in den Fallaway gekommen.
Ich habe so Luft erhalten
und bis ich nachher irgendwann ...
Da hat es mir abgestellt.
Ab da weiss ich nichts mehr,
bis ich nachher unten lag.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Tamara) Dominique und ich
kennen uns schon sehr lange.
Weil wir gleich alt sind, gingen wir
meist an die gleichen Rennen.
Wir waren auch zusammen im Skiklub.
Wir haben auch früh
zusammen trainiert.
Wir waren beide sehr ehrgeizig
und hatten Freude am Skifahren.
Dadurch hatten wir sofort
eine Verbindung.
Wir kamen gut miteinander aus
und verbrachten viel Zeit zusammen.
Am Anfang war es so,
dass sie ein Vorbild war.
Sie war damals die Schnellste,
die Beste.
Ich wollte so schnell sein wie sie.
Irgendwann waren wir im selben Ski-
klub und trainierten auch zusammen.
Wir hatten immer
ein lustiges Verhältnis,
weil wir komplett verschieden sind,
wie Yin und Yang.
Sie war immer sehr fokussiert
und ich habe noch anderes gesehen,
nicht nur den Skisport.
Daher waren wir diese Pole.
Dann ist daraus
langsam eine Freundschaft geworden.
Aber als wir jung waren,
war es doch eher eine Konkurrenz
und keine tiefe Freundschaft.
Wenn ich einen Moment meiner
Karriere herauspicken müsste,
der den Rest der Karriere
am meisten beeinflusste,
ist es sicher der Moment,
als Tamara aufhören musste.
In der Zeit,
als es für mich so schwierig war,
in der Mannschaft
wieder Anschluss zu finden
und mich wieder einzufügen,
war sie eine sehr wichtige Person.
Es hat mir extrem geholfen,
wenn ich mit ihr zusammen sein
und mich auch einmal
hinter ihr verstecken konnte.
Umgekehrt gab es
sicher auch Dinge,
in denen ich sie
unterstützen konnte.
Das hat nachher
sehr vieles beeinflusst.
Es führte sicher auch dazu,
dass ich mich noch mehr anpasste,
dass ich noch mehr versuchte,
mich irgendwo einzufügen,
wo ich gar nicht hineinpasste.
* Pulsierende Musik, im Hintergrund
Durchsage eines Speakers *
(TV-Kommentar) ...
bestätigt um 13.30 Uhr Ortszeit,
21.30 Uhr Schweizer Zeit.
Tamara, man hat lange gewartet,
aber jetzt kann man fahren.
Das ist doch eine gute Nachricht.
Ja, es ist eine positive Nachricht.
Die Verhältnisse sind im Vergleich
zum gestrigen Training
komplett anders - gestern
bei strahlendem Sonnenschein.
* Durchsage des Stadionspeakers *
Come on!
* Piepen *
* Startsignal *
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
* Durchsage des Stadionspeakers *
* Spannende Musik *
Ah!
* Kommentar der Stadionspeakerin *
* Jubel *
Oben sehr gut.
- Ja.
Aber halt Fishnet ...
Ich erwischte die Linie nicht.
Ester war auch so tief,
sie konnte besser ziehen.
Aber jetzt ...
Es hat extrem beschleunigt.
* Surren des Reissverschlusses *
Ich weiss nicht,
warum ich ängstlich bin.
Weil du dieses Jahr
noch wenig Speed gefahren bist.
Letztes und vorletztes Jahr auch.
Nach der Verletzung
ist es halt nun etwas anders.
Heute hast du im Vergleich
zu gestern einen Schritt gemacht.
Ja, aber die Fehler waren dumm,
der unten war richtig dumm.
Da erwischte ich ein Loch.
Es verdrehte mich und
ich habe das ganze Tempo verloren.
Ach!
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich glaube,
da muss sie ohnehin durch.
Das sind ganz wichtige Momente
einer Karriere.
Es sind nicht die,
die im Rampenlicht stehen,
aber es sind die,
die einen stärker machen
und aus denen man extrem viel lernt.
Ich glaube, heute hat Michelle
sehr viel gelernt.
Wir haben immer versucht,
das langfristig aufzubauen.
Einige Male ging es unglaublich gut,
gerade hier in Lake Louise,
wo es niemand erwartete.
Jetzt kippte es
auf die andere Seite.
Auch daraus kann sie unheimlich viel
für ihre Zukunft mitnehmen,
für die nächsten Rennen
und die nächsten Jahre.
* Sanfte Musik *
Für mich war der Sport
eine sehr grosse Lebensschule.
Ich musste durch sehr viele Tiefs,
ich erlitt sehr viele Rückschläge
und musste immer wieder aufstehen.
Wenn ich zurückschaue,
muss ich auch sagen,
dass man immer Chancen erhält,
im Sport etwas zu lernen.
Ob man wirklich etwas daraus lernt,
ist eine ganze andere Frage.
Jeder hat einen ganz anderen Weg.
Der Sport ist eine Lebensschule,
aber sie ist wie jede Schule.
Ob man am Ende etwas daraus
gelernt hat oder nicht,
hängt auch davon ab, wie man sie
erlebte und was man daraus machte.
* Sanfte Musik *
In Sotschi war ich sehr alleine.
Dieses Gefühl war so gross:
Ich hatte versagt -
bis zu einem gewissen Grad.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
(Mann am Start) 5, 4 ...
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
Am Start sagte ich zu mir selbst:
"Wenn du ins Ziel kommst, bevor du
auf die Anzeigetafel schaust,
musst du schnell
in dein Inneres schauen."
"Du musst darauf antworten,
ob es alles war,
ob du alles gegeben hast."
Ich bin ins Ziel gekommen,
schaute 1 Sek. auf den Boden
und überlegte mir, ob das alles war.
* Jubel *
(Mann) I Schwizari Dominique Gisin!
(Mann) Medaglia d'oro!
Medaglia d'oro per Dominique Gisin
e Tina Maze!
(Mann) Dominique Gisin!
* Triumphale Musik, Jubel *
Bei der Rangverkündigung war es
auch ein Moment des Alleinseins,
der sehr schön war.
Ich wusste, dass ich einen grossen
Teil davon alleine geschafft hatte,
dass ich dort stehen konnte.
* Schweizer Nationalhymne *
* Jubel, Applaus *
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Wie sagt man danke?
Elaballé bedeutet danke?
Und was heisst Guten Tag?
Eloallé.
Ah!
Also Elaballé bedeutet danke
und Eloallé guten Tag!
Okay, eloallé.
Während meiner Karriere
war mir immer klar,
dass ich mich für eine Organisation
engagieren will, die versucht,
in ärmeren Ländern,
Ländern,
die weniger Glück hatten als wir,
etwas voranzubringen.
Das war etwas,
das mir am Herzen lag.
C'est froid.
Das bin ich. Das ist Skifahren.
Dort ist es kalt,
nicht so heiss wie hier.
Ich bin die Kälte gewohnt.
* Sanfte Klänge, Stimmengewirr *
Das ist die Medaille.
Das bin auch ich, mit der Medaille.
* Dominique lacht. *
* Treibende Musik *
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Bei der ersten Reise
ist es mir extrem schwergefallen.
An jeder Ecke dachte man:
"Wenn ich da nur 100 Fr. gebe,
ändert sich alles."
Schritt für Schritt merkt man auch,
wie viel dahintersteckt,
wie viel es braucht, damit sich
nur die kleinsten Dinge ändern.
Und nicht nur ändern,
indem man einen Stein baut,
sondern dass sich etwas ändert,
weil man langfristig
eine Änderung bewirkt.
Diese langfristigen Änderungen
müssen aus der Gesellschaft
entstehen.
Ich glaube, dabei habe ich
auch sehr viel Demut gelernt.
* Treibende Musik, Rattern *
Ich kann helfen, etwas mitzutragen.
Ich kann ein bisschen helfen,
zu zeigen, was notwendig ist.
Aber am Schluss müssen v.a.
die Leute vor Ort befähigt werden,
sich selbst zu helfen.
Sie sind mündige Menschen
und sie können sich selber helfen.
Sie können sehr viel mehr, als wir
ihnen vielleicht manchmal zumuten.
Ich glaube, das hat mir sehr
geholfen, damit umgehen zu können,
dass ich nicht das Gefühl habe,
jemand zu sein,
der - ich weiss auch nicht -,
alles verändern kann.
Am Schluss kann ich nur versuchen,
ihnen zu helfen,
dass sie sich selbst helfen können.
* Sanfte Musik,
Vogelzwitschern, Zirpen *
Elaballé.
Weisst du, die Männer bemerken
eine schöne Frisur gar nicht.
Normalerweise stehen meine Haare
in alle Richtungen ab
und es stört sie gar nicht.
Zum Glück bist du da!
Es ist jetzt viel schöner!
Ich bringe euch jetzt
ein Wort auf Schweizerdeutsch bei:
Bonjour - c'est Grüezi.
(Beide) Grüezi.
- Grüezi, perfekt.
Und noch eines: merci.
Danke.
- (Beide, zaghaft) Danke.
(Mann) Merci.
- Danke.
(Die Kinder üben) Merci, danke.
* Kindergeschrei *
* Melancholische Musik *
* Perlende Klänge *
Natürlich kann man
in solchen Ländern
mit sehr kleinen Dingen jemandem
eine grosse Freude bereiten.
Ich glaube,
das ist bei uns nicht anders.
Bei uns gibt es auch Tage,
an denen wir Autogrammstunden geben.
Ein kleines Mädchen kommt und es ist
das Allergrösste in seinem Leben,
wenn es eine Autogrammkarte erhält
oder ein Foto mit uns machen kann.
Ich glaube,
das sollte man nie vergessen.
Egal, wie gut es einem geht.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
dass auch die kleinen Sachen
im Leben glücklich machen können.
* Trommelschlag *
* Strassenlärm *
* Sanfte, blubbernde Musik *
(Chris) Ihre grösste Herausforderung
war, ihren eigenen Weg zu finden
und auf diesem eigenen Weg
auch ihren Frieden zu finden.
Ich weiss noch, bis spät
in ihrer Karriere sagte sie mir,
dass sie gerne
viel mehr Rennen gewonnen hätte.
Ich sagte ihr immer: "Dominique,
was du geleistet hast ..."
"Was du mit deiner Geschichte
geleistet hast,
dafür bist du für sehr viele
Menschen viel mehr Inspiration,
als wenn du 20, 30 oder 40 Siege
errungen hättest."
Aber ich merke, dass sie einfach
auch eine wahre Athletin ist.
Eine Athletin, die den Wunsch hat,
viele Siege einzufahren.
* Brummende Klänge, Stimmengewirr *
Als ich mich nach meiner Karriere
an der ETH anmeldete,
war klar,
dass ich Physik machen wollte.
Ich habe mich
brutal ins Zeug gelegt
und habe wirklich alles gegeben.
Könnte ich noch einmal entscheiden,
würde ich wohl eher
an der Uni studieren,
weil dort das Tempo
einen Zacken ruhiger wäre.
Natürlich musste ich
an der ETH feststellen,
dass es beinahe
wie Spitzensport ist.
Die besten Jugendlichen aus
fast ganz Europa geben da Vollgas
und saugen alles auf, was ihnen
die genialsten Professoren mitgeben.
Es war unglaublich bereichernd,
einen kleinen Blick
davon zu erhaschen.
Es wäre beinahe so gewesen:
Man macht nach der Matura
das Studium, den Abschluss,
den Doktor und den Professor.
Und mit 32 findet man: "Komm ... "
Oder mit 29, sagen wir 29.
Mit 29 findet man: "Ich versuche es
trotzdem noch mit dem Skisport
und schaue, ob ich es
noch in den Weltcup schaffe."
Das ist schon
ein bisschen zu extrem.
* Dominique lacht. *
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Es geht nicht darum, permanent
in etwas besser werden zu wollen.
Aber ich hoffe, dass ich immer
etwas finde in meinem Leben,
bei dem ich
noch etwas verändern kann,
noch etwas mitgestalten kann.
Wenn das nicht mehr da ist ...
Wenn die Freude am Mitgestalten,
am Mitentwickeln nicht mehr da ist,
ist für mich wie nichts mehr da.
Darum hoffe ich schon,
dass immer etwas da sein wird,
bis zu meinem Lebensende -
und wenn es das ist, dass ich
mit 80 lerne Cello zu spielen.
Das ist für mich das Leben.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020